hey guys I only have a little bit of
time before I go to Emerald City Comic
Con I don't have time to review a movie
but enough time to give you my thoughts
and bald jesse eisenberg because that
was the onslaught on my twitter when it
was revealed but on [ __ ] I mean [ __ ]
onslaught it was revealed people were
like I told G's gonna be awesome look at
him he looks awesome he awesome and you
know you know Tong my these are my
thoughts on it because it's interesting
enough it's a picture is it enough to
sell me on Jesse Eisenberg being Lex
Luthor no it's a dude scowling looking
sinister in a black and white picture
anyone's going to seem perfect for a
villainous role at that point maybe I'm
being an [ __ ] maybe I'm being too
tough but I'm just saying it's just a
picture now granted what's brought me
over to the side of bat flick being
possibly a good Batman is primarily
pictures you see pictures like that I'm
like that is Batman difference is that
looks like Batman doesn't look like Ben
Affleck at all it's like a
transformation there Jesse Eisenberg's
Lex Luthor picture looks exactly how I
thought Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor
would luck it looks like bald Jesse
Eisenberg there's no shock there when I
said I think it's the wrong casting
having Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor in
my head I had that exact picture all
right maybe not exact because he has a
pretty good scowl and the bald head does
make him age a bit yeah he actually does
look 30 he doesn't look 16 at this point
I can only describe it like this it's
like you see that picture you're like
cool but I know how Jesse Eisenberg
sounds and Jesse Eisenberg's voice does
not match the picture I will say this he
could pull it off for sure but he's
going to have to be something we've
never seen him be before which is a
voice actor ain't talking about Rio cuz
he was still Jesse Eisenberg and Rio
he'll need to change his voice he'll
need to do something different than
Jesse Eisenberg's voice if he looks like
that he's still thrown out first rule of
magic always be the smartest guy in the
room he's not gonna bite i'ma be like
you're Jesse Eisenberg with a bald head
maybe we could maybe that's gonna be the
compromise we make for people who are
like no he's perfect people like me who
are like always not it's like yeah he
looks fine if he has a different voice
can we agree on that [ __ ] cuz otherwise
they're doing the social network guy as
Lex Luthor and I just don't want to see
that keep in mind these are the casting
people who made gal gadot Wonder Woman I
think that's stupid too so give you my
thoughts on this because a lot of people
on Twitter wanted hear my thoughts on
this so at that point I give it to you
guys Jesse Eisenberg's picture as Lex
Luthor Lex Luthor are bald Jesse
Eisenberg what do you think it looks
like whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more